the warm Waters in the Gulf of Mexico
are making hurricane Ian even stronger
from space it seen swirling over the
Caribbean
this woman in Cuba Wades through Waters
inside what's left of her home
it was a disaster I've never seen this
before we lost everything nothing is
left as you can see
now Florida is next you need to evacuate
now the governor of Florida told people
in its Southwest to leave as the waves
get taller and stronger right now in the
State of Florida there's about 8 000
customers that are out of power that's
mostly in southeast Florida due to some
of the things that we have seen but of
course that number will be into the
millions uh relatively shortly with the
lack of power many are downloading a
free app called Zello that works like a
walkie-talkie and can be used with
little to no cell phone signal it was
the number one downloaded app during
Hurricane Harvey in 2017. other
preparations include stocking up on food
and water and this creative trick if you
have especially an old laptop sitting
around and the storm is coming keep it
plugged in keep the battery charged and
then even if you never turn the laptop
on it's basically a gigantic battery
pack that you can use to get several
charges out of your phone
despite various tips officials say they
are still concerned residents may be
apathetic I do have concerns about
complacency we're talking about impacts
in a part of Florida that hasn't seen a
major direct impact in nearly a hundred
years there's also parts of Florida
where there's a lot of new residents
that have never experienced this type of
threat so my message to them is still
take this very seriously the National
Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
predicts six to ten hurricanes will form
in the Atlantic this year
half are expected to be major
Leah Harding Al Jazeera